why is the government trying to ban
Tick-Tock more than 150 million
Americans use the app but Nanny State
politicians think they should have the
power to control what kinds of content
you are allowed to see here are three
reasons why Banning Tick Tock is an
idiotic idea one the dangers of tick
tock have been overstated now it's true
you can find really vile content on the
platform it's not all Dance videos but
that's not unique to tick tock there's
bad stuff in all corners of the internet
two it's hypocritical yes Tick Tock is
China owned and that worries us but the
US government has pressured American
companies to censor speech if Congress
is really so worried about the
government controlling the discourse
they should put their own house in order
first three a tick tock ban could easily
be weaponized the restrict act empowers
the Commerce Department to take action
against foreign threats this is the
Patriot Act 2.0 if we give the
government more tools to police Tick
Tock they're going to use them against
all of us so let's leave Tick Tock alone
not just because of the dance videos but
also because of the First Amendment
[Music]